[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 abrimos Este
programa con un encuentro artístico muy
especial entre Colombia y Francia ellos
son los integrantes de la filarmónica
joven de Colombia tienen entre 16 y 24
años y cada año participan a proyectos
con artistas internacionales como los
franceses del prestigioso quadware
empezaron el 2023 juntos con nueve días
de residencia y tres conciertos una
colaboración fluida a pesar de tener
idiomas diferentes ya que estás dos
formaciones musicales comparten el mismo
objetivo crear y presentar la música
clásica de una manera diferente
fuimos a encontrarnos con ellos
tocar con los ojos vendados un reto que
aceptaron con entusiasmo los violinistas
violoncelistas y con trabajos de la
filarmónica joven de Colombia con esta
inédita puesta en escena
contar una historia de censura y
opresión los maestros y los alumnos no
se conocían tienen ahora unos días para
preparar un choque juega con los códigos
de la música de cámara ha sido súper
peculiar y una oportunidad maravillosa
puesto que estamos reuniendo varias
artes en este proyecto Y eso hace que en
el momento
del concierto del público pueda tener
una perspectiva más amplia diferente que
es lo que buscamos hacer esa creatividad
que estamos logrando y ha sido
espectacular
son personas con una capacidad artística
gigantesca son intérpretes increíbles y
Ver cómo ver el proceso creativo de
cerca es fascinante es muy inspirador y
ellos han sido muy generosos con
nosotros
también creo están emocionados de ver
las posibilidades que tiene el Pues el
performance que estamos haciendo y pues
ha sido una experiencia muy gratificante
en casi 35 años de existencia es la
primera vez que los franceses del si
viajan a Colombia quedaron impresionados
por el nivel y la pasión de estos
jóvenes músicos colombianos
[Música]
lo que encuentro aquí es que hay quizás
una especie de urgencia la vida es
difícil entrar en las orquestas es muy
muy difícil no hay muchas plazas Así que
les sentimos hipermotivados por
enriquecerse quizás más que en Francia
donde estamos un poco en una especie de
Confort y luego esta inmensa confianza
que tienen en un cuarteto que muchos no
conocían llevamos dos años hablando de
este proyecto desde que desgraciadamente
hubo la pandemia de por medio vieron
vídeos de nosotros y se dijeron hay algo
fuera de lo común que quiero vivir
con maestros internacionales y clases de
inglés y de alemán la orquesta Busca
responder al problema de empleabilidad
de los jóvenes músicos sinfónicos pero
les quieren también enseñar que no solo
hay futuro en el exterior del país lo
que queremos al final es que entiendan
también que más allá de ser músicos y
grandes artistas que se pueden ir por
supuesto a estudiar a trabajar un tiempo
afuera hay un país Aquí que los vio
nacer que los acompañó para que llegaran
donde están y que hay una
responsabilidad muy grande de todos
nosotros devolver y de construir país
acá Colombia hoy tiene una oportunidad
grandísima Están pasando muchas cosas
que en muchos otros países no pasan y
siempre les decimos como acá van a poder
hacer muchas cosas liderar mucho el
cambio y eso quizás de las cosas más
importantes
la filarmónica joven de Colombia quiere
consolidar una comunidad de músicos al
internacional
por eso trabajan en abrir el panorama de
posibilidades a estos jóvenes y
motivarles a seguir El ejemplo de
quadware devic para romper las barreras
de la música clásica
[Aplausos]
Hablamos ahora de las noticias
culturales de estos últimos días
empezando con la liberación en Irán del
cineasta rafar pani salió de la prisión
de vida enteran el 3 de febrero dos días
después de haber empezado su huelga de
hambre al anunció su citó un inmenso
alivio dentro de la comunidad
cinematográfica tanto iraní como
internacional muy movilizada desde su
detención en julio del año pasado el
multipremiado director de 62 años habrá
pasado más de 200 días entre rejas que
da ahora en Libertad bajo fianza pero
muchos otros intelectuales y opositores
siguen en prisión en Irán
y el mismo día el mundo de la moda dijo
Adiós al legendario diseñado Franco
español Paco ravana conocido por sus
perfumes superventas y sus trajes
metálicos futuristas su Audaz selección
de materiales su visión vanguardista y
su libertad creativa influyeron en toda
una generación de diseñadores de moda
murió a los 88 años
éramos Este programa con los resultados
de los premios Grammys durante esta
ceremonia de los Oscar de la música
todos los ojos están puestos en la
estrella de la música pop y Beyoncé la
cantante estadounidense se convirtió en
la artista más laureada de todos los
tiempos con 32 estatuillas Grammy pero a
pesar del indiscutible éxito de su
séptimo disco reniecense el premio
supremo al mejor álbum se le resistió En
beneficio del británico Harry Styles
para Harris House un premio que también
merecía el puertorriqueño Bad Bunny para
un verano sin ti cuya performance
inyectó energía una ceremonia que cada
año se vuelve más plana entre los otros
galardonados que destacaron este año
liso ganó el premio a la grabación del
año por su canción
y marcó la noche con un discurso Muy
conmovedor El rapero kendrick Lamar se
consagró con su quinto disco Mister
morrowland
gramófonos y la cantante estadounidense
de jazz Samara Joy de 23 años se fue con
el premio la mejor artista revelación
[Música]
Nos despedimos con el artista británico
Sam Smith que también se fue con un
premio Grammy le deseamos el mismo Éxito
para su nuevo tema entre disco y pop and
Friends Gracias a ustedes por su
confianza y sigan con nosotros hay más
cultura en Frozen 4.com
[Música]